good evening everyone and welcome to
tonight's meeting of the Commonwealth of
California co-sponsored by codys
bookstore here in Berkeley tonight's
program is brought to you from the
historic Julia Morgan berkeley design
berkeley city club in berkeley
california is my pleasure to welcome you
both the viewers of c-span and
commonwealth of radio audience my name
is Judson true and under your chair for
this evening we invite all the listeners
and viewers of tonight's program to
visit us on the world wide web at
commonwealth club allure org and if you
would please use the question cards on
your chairs for tonight's program we
would most appreciate it it would be
collected during the first half of the
speech and now to introduce today's
speaker it is my pleasure to introduce
and invite to the podium mr. Sean Lance
the CEO of the chyron corporation Sean
or good evening yeah thank you it's my
pleasure to introduce the feeder j2 to
you tonight peter is currently the
economics editor at the BBC a position
that he's held since 1990 educated at
Oxford and a veteran of the Royal Navy a
fetus long and distinguished career
includes government service as well as
work as a journalist and historian he
served for six years in the British
Treasury Department before joining the
times as its economists economics editor
now after a decade at the paper he was
appointed ambassador to United States
back in 1977 where he served for two
years in the mid 80s he was chairman of
the National Council of voluntary
organizations and editor of banking
world now he's a frequent presence on
British television and his book The
Wealth of Man which he is here to
discuss with us this evening is the
subject of a major six-part British BBC
documentary that he himself will narrate
the wealth of man is an ambitious work
that seeks to chronicle the human
struggle to satisfy the craving for
material improvement from 10,000 BC to
the present the book is not only an
effort to understand the past that is
clearly a serious work of history
Peter's aim is to help us grapple with
the uncertain economic future of all of
the world's peoples in an age of what
has become to be called perhaps
incorrectly globalization now I will
certainly not seek to explain the book
any further since we are fortunate
enough to have the author with us here
tonight please join me in welcoming
ambassador Peter J thank you
chairman ladies and gentlemen I'm
extremely grateful for this opportunity
given me by the Commonwealth Club to
come and talk about my book to present
my book to this evening and I'm
extremely grateful to you chairman feel
for your introduction before i come in
further detail to that perhaps i should
ask for your forgiveness if in the
course of my remarks i appear to have
adopted a rather extraordinary posture
here at this rostrum I want to warn you
in advance that it's not that I'm trying
to give an imitation of Jerry Lewis
imitating a person with a severe pain in
the back trying to address a very
difficult pool shot it it is that I am
blessed or cursed depending on how you
look at it with a very great height and
very short sight and that in order to
therefore to bring my eyes within the
necessary maximum distance of my notes
on the podium it is sometimes necessary
for me to adopt this odd posture but I
hope you will forgive me introductions
German are are very important and you're
very generous and efficient introduction
this evening I noticed you tiptoed
tactfully round my three and a half year
period with the publisher Robert Maxwell
you're tactful introduction reminded me
in some ways of the time when which you
did refer to I used to represent my
country in this country the custom then
was and you went some of that way this
evening chairman to give more or less
the full curriculum vitae the official
biography of the speaker word for word
and if you're an ambassador you get
called upon to say a few words as we say
in the trade several times a day as a
result of which I found myself listening
to my own CV or resume a several times a
day I used to think that if I heard it
many more times I might come to believe
it but it always used to cheer me up in
one way because it contained a sentence
that was a wonderful example of
something that I had learnt many years
before as a very junior civil servant in
the British Treasury Department
something called the art of economy in
drafting now that's got nothing to do
i'm glad to say with economics it has to
do with producing the words that are
required for some situation a minister
is going to write a letter to a
constituent or make a speech or answer a
question in parliament or whatever it
may be to produce the words that are
required with the least possible efforts
on the part of the civil servant having
to produce those words and that
mechanism clearly had been at work
because when I arrived in Washington it
must have struck some officials a
middle-ranking official I expect that
the existing document called the
biography of the Ambassador would no
longer quite do because there was now
after all the different ambassador my
predecessor I should explain had given
great and distinguished service to his
country in some now indeed then
forgotten colonial war and risen to the
rank of something like Major General now
as a result of all these circumstances
there was this sentence because I can
see that this official had thought that
though the existing document wouldn't do
it would be an awful pity to throw away
all of that excellent drafting in the
existing document as a result of which
the worst
sentence which read mr. J after a long
distinguished and gallant galit period
of service in the Royal Navy rose to the
rank of sub-lieutenant assembling tenant
I have to tell you is the lowest drink
in the Royal Navy as I'm sure it
probably is also in the United States
Navy but at least that illustrates the
importance of introductions now you
mentioned the BBC chairman i should say
as i always do on such occasions that as
everybody knows the BBC has absolutely
no opinions on any subject whatsoever
under the sun and if anything i say
sounds in any way like an opinion i can
assure you you must be mistaken and i
shall of course denied now let me come
to the book i admitted once that i'm not
quite sure how on an occasion like this
I ought to present it since the book
tries to be a history of the world or at
least of mankind's time so far on earth
I don't think it would be practical or
indeed in durable for you if I was to
try to give you a potted version of the
book in these remarks either I should
succeed rather unlikely which would
remove the need for you to read the book
or more probably I should fail and put
you off the whole thing now you may of
course very fairly asked what I suppose
my qualifications were to address such
an ambitious task and why wasn't a
proper academic University historian
retained to do the job well legend I
don't really think it is for me to try
to answer that question my publisher did
me the honor of asking me and the BBC
did me the honor of asking me to present
and be the author of the television
series and I found both those tasks
irresistibly fascinating I've always
believed that the job of the journalist
and that's what I've been most of my
life and of the historian our logic
be the same what they boiled down to is
the task of finding out reporting and
explaining those three words to find out
to report and to explain what has
happened all history I think an all
journalism is embodied in those simple
words trying to explain what I think are
important and sometimes complicated
events and issues on paper and on radio
and in television for laymen is what I
spent a good slice of my life doing and
I very much enjoyed in addition the
basic question of economic history how
and why did mankind get from there to
here from wondering about 12,000 years
ago picking blackberries and taking
potshots at passing woolly mammoths and
not looking at all like the species most
likely to succeed to where we are today
when the chief threat to our survival as
a species may well be ourselves that
question must command i think the
interest of almost anybody who thinks
about human life on this planet anyway
it certainly commanded mine having spent
much of my life trying to follow and
understand rather ephemeral economic
events a boom here a bust there a
currency crisis here and there it seemed
rank cowardice to duck the challenge of
trying at least once before I became
terminally Gaga to write down a coherent
though it could certainly never be
definitive account of the whole economic
story of man trying both to tell the
tale as it happened and in the process
to answer the central question of
economic history what is it that makes
different societies and the same society
at different times prosper and stagnate
grow
and decline leap forward and then
sometimes fall back on that very body
has been in my mind the agenda of the
book my answer contains two basic and
linked thoughts one is that government
matters as a key determine both
positively and frequently negatively of
economic success and the second is that
economic history proceeds in a manner
somewhat reminiscent of the basic steps
of the classical waltz which are as far
as I remember one step forward and two
steps sideways and the sideways may
sometimes be slightly backwards or
sometimes be slightly forwards now this
waltz idea is explained in the book
early on and then by repeated reference
in most chapters as the story unfolds
and where it seems most apt I'd like to
share with you the key passage in the
book introducing it the walls motive
simply asserts as a frequently
encountered pattern though certainly not
as an iron law that one from time to
time and economic advances made for
example the development of Agriculture
by chance opportunity or by development
in knowledge or technique which
apparently enables more mouths to be fed
or existing mouths to be better fed or
living standards to be raised in one way
or another to this advance provokes
predatory threats for example external
Raiders or internal idlers from one or
another species of outsider or free
rider who hopes to secure the fruits of
the advance for himself without the
costs or effort required to support the
advance and three these threats invite
and they may or may not attract
a social political solution for example
structured settlements with rulers
whereby the original advance is
protected from predation by rules
prohibiting or discouraging such conduct
and all by direct policing and military
defense it is ladies and gentlemen the
stability or otherwise of the social
political solutions achieved in this
third step that frequently determines
how far where and for how long the
fruits of the original purely economic
advance are enjoyed it is because step
one provokes step two and because step
three can always fail that whole
civilizations as well as lesser economic
units are frequently found to retrogress
to go backwards economically and
sometimes to fail altogether although of
course natural calamity can sometimes do
the job without the aid of human
political in competence or military
inferiority it's for this reason that
the economic historian who wishes to
explain man's economic advance and its
frequent interruptions and failures is
necessarily drawn deeply into the
observation and description of the
social cultural and political structures
and values which man has devised to
facilitate and protect his economic
progress without them without pure
without without them purely economic
advance isn't enough and it soon fails
and however much the economic historian
seeks to confine his agenda to purely
economic events and their explanation
he's rapidly obliged to concern himself
with the total organization and
governance of societies if not for their
own sake at least as necessary
ingredients in the understanding of the
purely economic story
Adam Smith the great Adam Smith went
before us in this as in so much else
indeed he diagnosed a version of the
waltz motif at the very heart of his
explanation of the wealth of man and of
Nations and of why they should grow he
called it the natural progress of
opulence it all starts he believed in
the nature of man in his innate
curiosity and competitiveness allied to
a perpetual disposition to ameliorate
his material condition in other words to
seek wealth this Smith thought led to
the division of labor and the growth of
knowledge similar in broad concept to
step one of our waltz motif this thesis
immediately ran into its antithesis in
the form of what Smith saw as the
practical inhibitions regrowth mainly
predation by the powerful within a
society and by outside invaders as well
as by the monopolistic tendencies of
merchants and manufacturers and by
slavery synthesis was then found where
success occurred in social and political
developments such as the emergence of
towns and markets the evolution of the
middle class the political matrix of
citizenship state power rents and taxes
and the reinforcing legitimization of
these structures by value systems based
on kinship status the state and religion
now that reading from the book I hope
makes the link between the waltz motif
thought and the importance of government
obvious for the third step of each waltz
motif is an essentially a political one
it's the moment at which a society
either finds a way of sharing and
enjoying the increment in prosperity
which has occurred at step one and which
has been threatened at step two or fails
to do so with the likely consequence
that the original step 4
word is not sustained and may even be
converted into a retreat that ability or
inability of people in groups ranging
from early villages of a few dozen to
modern countries of hundreds of millions
of inhabitants determines whether they
grow or decline what is required is an
act of government perhaps of
self-government perhaps of
constitution-making but essentially any
way of rulemaking whereby it is
determined how wealth may be created in
a society how it shall be shared and
what forms of ownership with what rights
shall be recognized and protected if the
rules don't leave those who generate
economic wealth with sufficient
incentives to keep doing so production
and enterprise will decline if the rules
don't leave those who lack wealth with
the sufficient stake in the society they
too may withdraw from or even disrupt
such an economy good government gets
these balances right maximizing both
opportunity and fairness as perceived by
its citizens as well as providing for an
economic and effective defense against
external attack bad government does the
reverse in the television series that
tell you spoke of Chairman we developed
this thought in front of a splendid
great fresco by the Italian Renaissance
painter lorenzetti in the town hall at
Siena which vividly depicts the contrast
one wall is good government the next
wall is bad government now in the book I
illustrate the theme with a long
quotation from young Chang's wild swans
which i described despite the fact that
it's essentially a personal memoir as
arguably the best most penetrating and
enjoyable textbook of the nature of
economic growth that I have ever read my
favorite passage includes the following
all around me jung chang rights
memories of being six years old
uplifting music blared from loudspeakers
and there were banners posters and huge
slogans painted on the walls proclaiming
long live the great leap forward and
everybody makes steel mao chairman mao
ordered steel output to be doubled in
one year nearly a hundred million
peasants were pulled out of agricultural
work and into steel production they had
be in the labor force producing much of
the country's food mountains were
stripped bare of trees for fuel but the
output of this mass production amounted
only to what people called cattle
droppings meaning useless turns mouths
fixation on steel went largely
unquestioned as did his other obsessions
he took a dislike to sparrows they
devour grain so every household was
mobilised we sat outside ferociously
beating any metal object from symbols to
saucepans to scare the scat was to scare
the sparrows off the trees so that they
would eventually drop dead from
exhaustion that summer 1958 all of China
was organized into these new units
people's communes each containing
between two thousand and twenty thousand
households the regime effectively banned
eating at home every peasant had to eat
in the commune canteen the peasants
filed into the canteens every day after
work and ate to their heart's content
they consumed and wasted the entire food
reserve in the countryside with no
incentive to work they just went to the
fields and had a good snooze agriculture
was also neglected because of the
priority given to steal many of the
peasants were exhausted from having to
spend long hours finding fuel scrap iron
and iron ore and keeping the furnaces
going the fields were often left to the
women and children who had to do
everything by
hand as the animals were busy making
their contribution to steel production
when harvest time came in autumn 1958
few people were in the fields the
failure to get in the harvest in 1958
flashed a warning that a food shortage
was on its way as the 60s began a great
famine spread across the whole of China
and accepted estimate yunxiang rights of
the death toll for the whole country is
around 30 million people now that from
yung Chang isn't I think an
exceptionally vivid example of the
ravages which bad government really bad
government can inflict on any economy
but we can find in contemporary Russia
the other form of bad government not to
much but too little or at least failing
to fulfill the primary duties of
government to create sufficient social
stability and protection from lawless
bullies for normal economic life to
develop history provides many other
examples of the disastrous consequences
of anarchy and of course war itself
however important as government is to
the story and helpful as I believe the
waltz motif can be in picturing some of
its patterns I would mislead you badly
if I left you with the impression that I
thought that was the whole of the
economic story of mankind in the book I
also say that the discovery of
Agriculture and the discovery of
compound growth of economic output
otherwise the industrial revolution
what's followed it were changes of
profound or importance than any others
though of course it remains incumbent
upon us to continue to delve into their
own antecedent causes agriculture
revolutionized the productivity of land
and industry revolutionized the
productivity of labour between them they
account for if they don't completely
explain the main quantitative changes in
mankind
material condition when the noted
british archaeologist archaeologist
stephen milan said that if you look at
the last 100,000 years the start of
farming is the biggest transformation
that has occurred and after it has
happened well the rest just unfolds as
history he is half right the great
growth in human numbers is thereby
enabled but the other half the great
growth in living standards in the
industrial world over the last two
centuries the final seconds of
archaeological time is more than just
history over simplifying bravely but not
I think intolerably one may say that
agriculture enabled mankind to increase
a thousandfold in number over the last
10,000 years we saw in chapter one that
one hunter-gatherer needed something
like 25 square kilometers of favorable
territory to make a living whereas even
the earliest agriculture could support
20 people on a single square kilometre a
ratio of 500 to 1 though it naturally
took most of the time since then for
that potential to be anywhere nearly
fully exploited if we disregard new
additions of favorable territories since
the earliest days we would still only
need by arithmetic a microscopic further
annual growth in agricultural land
efficiency of less than naught point
naught five percent a year to provide
the extra food necessary to feed the
thousand fold increase a thousand times
greater that has occurred in our
population over that period in other
words the discovery of agriculture
enabled the population to increase 500
times and improvements in its
sufficiency enabled one further doubling
of that result actual food supply has of
course increased even more than that
because four-fifths of the world's
population are living today
at better than subsistence levels that
that extra can be ascribed to the impact
of the Industrial Revolution on
agriculture as in the role of the
tractor and in the Green Revolution what
agriculture did not do was greatly to
raise the productivity of farm labor or
indeed of anybody's labor because the
Wilson to anybody else indeed we saw in
chapter one that early farm societies
work much longer hours and lived harder
lives than the hunter-gatherers they
replaced that helps to explain why the
main effect of the huge increase in land
productivity went as the millennia
rolled by into increased population
rather than into higher living standard
the land could produce 500 times as much
food and eventually a thousand times as
much but if we disregard the extra
effects of the Industrial Revolution on
food production we would expect it to
have taken something approaching as many
people to produce each hundredweight of
food and therefore eventually 500 times
as many people to produce by 1960 the
five hundred fold increase in potential
global food supply when the population
was in fact three billion which equals
six million which is what it was when we
started 12,000 years ago x 500 now
likewise industry by investing in and
otherwise harnessing an indefinitely
growing body of technical skill and
knowledge to the task of increasing
economic output in quantity and quality
gave mankind for the first time the
prospect of significant output growth at
compound interest for an indefinitely
long future period and this growth
unlike the growth in farm production
didn't require a more or less equivalent
increase in human numbers to produce it
it could be produced by an increase in
output per head and this over two
centuries delivered was a leading
economic historian DN McCluskey calls
the heart of the matter 12
the factor by which real incomes per
head now exceed what it was in 1780 in
countries that have experienced modern
economic growth no other episode of
enrichment approaches modern economic
growth in what it has done for the
living standards of those humans
affected by it just as nothing
approaches what the discovery of
agriculture has done for human numbers
in this way I think we can reconcile my
vans view crudely paraphrase crudely
paraphrased as saying that after the
Agricultural Revolution it was all over
by the history with John Maynard Keynes
view that there was no significant
progress in the human condition before
1700 or as he actually phrased it in a
passage that bears quoting from the
earliest times of which we have record
back say to 2,000 years before Christ
down to the beginning of the 18th
century there was no very great change
in the standard of life of the average
man living in the civilized centers of
the earth ups and downs certainly
visitations of plague famine and war
golden intervals but no progressive
violet change some periods perhaps fifty
percent better than others at the utmost
one hundred percent better in the four
thousand years which ended say in AD
1700 but one of the future canes
believed when he wrote the words I have
just quoted that within a hundred years
by the year 2030 mankind would have
solved its economic problem namely the
struggle for subsistence in the world
where the necessities of life was guess
compound economic growth he believed
would do the job now exactly 100 years
earlier thomas babington macaulay the
great british historian and essayist had
challenged the pessimists of his time to
say why 1930 shouldn't be as much better
than 1830 as he said
30 was better than 17 30 when Daniel
Defoe the author of Treasure Island had
recently written his memorable tour of
Great Britain well ladies and gentlemen
here is my own conclusion which will I
hope whet your appetite for the story
which leads up to it in the book it's
time to answer our own Malthusian
question how sure should we be that the
planet can supply and otherwise sustain
a geometric progression of production
either to meet the needs of an
exponentially growing population all to
fulfill the aspirations of a stable
population for exponentially rising
living standards on that more than on
any other question should depend our
answers to McCauley's question why we
shouldn't expect the future to deliver
the same glorious onward march of
progress that distinguishes the past and
to Cannes this question whether we have
finally solved the economic problem our
answer to the first is that it can't be
taken for granted as a propositioned
arrival from with any economic science
nor as a reliable consequence of the
fact that Malthusian rigors seem to have
been avoided by large parts of the human
race for at least a few centuries nor
yet as a certain guarantee given by the
ceaseless advance of science maybe
global population will stop rising for a
while in the middle of the 21st century
and maybe it will not resume its growth
before that century's end though these
are very big maybes but mankind's
potential collision course with the
limits or at least limitations of his
physical environment will not be
deflected simply by demographic
stability the progress of opulence as a
disposition of mankind will continue
gross domestic products per head will
rise and therefore GDPs will rise where
the fourfold eight
or 12-fold every hundred years and if
this requires a systemic fouling of our
own nest by mankind fouling of a kind
that feeds back to us as climate change
rising oceans expanding deserts
vanishing forests and intensifying
conflicts of interest between the west
and the east and between the north and
south then our growing rather than the
presently falling proportion of mankind
may be struggling for subsistence
finding themselves the unfortunates
sandwich between the rock of growth and
the hard place of the planets not quite
limitless capacity that is what Malthus
feared was mankind's fated lot to return
however high he soared and however long
he might for what for a while escaped
from the trap to the point where his
numbers were curtailed by the privations
to which at least parts of the species
were subjectively such an outcome would
obviously be the opposite the antithesis
of Cain's prediction of a final solution
to the economic problem of how to
subsist in a world of scarcity Keynes's
optimism was based on the formidable
potential of economic growth at compound
interest of the kind unleashed by the
Industrial Revolution he included
providers that population growth about
population growth and war but naturally
enough the possibility that such growth
itself might have such an impact on our
planetary environment as to damage it as
a human habitat and so create a problem
of subsistence for even stable numbers
of people didn't occur to him but even
without that new peril there are other
reasons for being sure that by 2030
Keynes's century from when Kayne's wrote
we will not be suffering as he suggested
some kind of nervous breakdown as a
consequence of being deprived of the
purpose for which evolution has so
deeply
and program programmed us namely to
sweat for our daily bread canes were the
creature of the Cambridge of GE more and
of the bluesberry of lytton strachey in
Virginia Woolf he believed that the
highest good resided not in great piles
of wealth but in the best states of mind
that could be enjoyed by those who had
the good fortune and the ability to
contemplate truth beauty and goodness
and to immerse themselves in the joys of
friendship for him therefore it was
possible to believe in a finite level of
wealth comfortably above subsistence
beyond which mankind would be free to
return to some of the most sure and
certain principles of religion and
traditional virtue that avarice is vice
that the exaction of usury is a
misdemeanor and the love of money is
detestable that those who walk most
truly in the paws of virtue and sade
wisdom who are who take these thought
for the morrow we shall once more value
ends above means and prefer the good to
the useful he wrote well we may dream of
such a world we may add marriage and we
may hanker after it but we can't believe
in it because it reckons without Darwin
and without Adam Smith to the progress
of opulence does not stop when
subsistence is left behind and those who
choose the life of leisure and the
pleasures of the mind hi thinking and
the living standards of Cambridge in the
1930s will be outrun and outflanked in
wealth power and survival by those who
continue to obey what Keynes
contemptuously called the pseudo moral
principles which have hag witness for
200 years by which we have exalted some
of the most distasteful of human
qualities into the position of the
highest virtue those semi criminal semi
pathological propensities he wrote which
one hands over with a shudder to the
specialists in mental disease such as
all kinds of social customs and economic
practices affecting the distribution
wealth and of economic rewards and
penalties which we now maintained at all
costs however distasteful and unjust
they may be in themselves because they
are tremendously useful in promoting the
accumulation of capital gains dream of
subverting the bourgeois world by
bursting through into a higher patter of
affluence in which greed and thrift and
toil are superfluous is I think
unrealizable not because such levels of
output are unattainable they will be
attained even earlier than Cain surmised
but because the propensity to go on
striving for yet higher peaks will
continue in the breasts of enough
members of the human race to ensure that
is it is they and not those who opt for
the economic bliss of cultivating the
arts of life rather than the activities
of purpose who dominate the subsequent
story in that sense Darwin always wins
in the end now ladies and gentlemen I
had intended to add there is other
readings from my book which I show you
that it's not all such solemn stuff that
there are some lighter passages and we
have some fun along the way but I think
as the clock is moving on I should
conclude at that point and allow you to
ask any questions if you have them and
then I shall know that I'm talking about
things that at least interest you and
this time we can come back to the the
lighter moments later thank you very
much indeed
thank you very much ambassador Peter J
author of the wealth of man as you can
imagine we have a large number of
questions maybe not covering 12,000
years but definitely definitely covering
a wide variety of subjects and the first
question will be does democratic
capitalism as it exists today have the
capacity to address some of the
long-term strategic economic social
political environmental questions that
you described as crucial well thank you
that's question that goes absolutely to
the heart of the matter and if I were to
stand here and say I could give you the
answer to that question in two sentences
I should be claiming something which you
would know was not true I think the
challenge implied in that question is
arguably the greatest certainly the
greatest challenge in political
development that we face if I may just
take a little corner of the question it
seems to me to be reasonably clear at
this moment that our society faces a
number of challenges a small number of
which could be regarded as global in the
sense that they seem to have the
potential of threatening literally the
survival of the human species on this
planet not over the millions and
zillions of years from which we all know
everything will be swept away by
astronomical changes but even in the
next century or so there is no doubt I
think in my mind to take one example
that the changes affecting our climate
well they don't affect don't seem to
imply the threat to the survival of the
human species certainly implied threats
of a very profound kind to its habitat
now one of the things that he's very
clear about the
his threats is that they take place over
a long time that the action required to
deal with them is action which needs to
be taken a very long time before as it
were twelve o'clock a very long time
before one is facing catastrophe
catastrophe on the ground decades and
maybe even more than decades now and
secondly it is clear that that action
needs to be effective at a global level
climate change is not something that can
be dealt with country by country let
alone state by state or locality by
locality now we also know that it is a
very clear characteristic of the
political process every as we have it
democratic capitalism is like that
insofar as it reacts to problems that
confronted it does the last possible
minute it is not a characteristic of
that process that people rush out to
vote or to write their politicians and
say hey look something very terribly may
be going to happen in 100 years time I
think you should increase my taxes or I
think you should do something else which
will cause call for immediate sacrifice
on the country there rather than
supposed to say that the opposite should
happen and if somebody else says it
should happen they're extremely inclined
to say that it that there is no need for
this to question the premises or even or
to suggest that the proposed solution
even if in theory it's necessary is in
one way or another unfair not to be
recast in a different form it is
extremely hard in other words for large
democratic societies to grapple with
these problems in a timely way it is
infinitely more hard for a world of 6
billion people going on eight point nine
billion weren't supposed to level off
towards the middle of the present
century to make
early and effective decisions and then
to police them and implement them for a
whole globe in made up of small and
medium sized and one or two large nation
states none of whom come under the
government or control of any global
authority who therefore could could make
such a decision and it remains therefore
for global solutions to be negotiated as
best possible between this large number
of extremely unequal ramshackle acts
left over by accidents of history nation
states now from time to time they seemed
to rise to these challenges or half rise
to the more two-thirds rise to them and
something gets done but to put one's
hand on one's heart and say that it is a
probability let alone a certainty that
for each and every one of the global
problems the global threats to the
survival of mankind all the societies
who make up the global community will in
a timely way reach the right conclusions
come together and agree on the right
conclusions establish a implement and
police programs to that effect seems to
me to be to be preaching something which
runs contrary to all our experience of
democratic life it is the length of the
time scale and the global nature of the
problems which puts it on the face of it
beyond the normal reflexes responses and
capabilities of the political system
that we have and therefore I do think
that we have very profound reasons to
worry about this now that's not a reason
not advocating despair I think that if
we succeed in recognizing that problem
as a fundamental problem of political
architecture in the world
we may yet as we have done in the past
in various ways rise even to that
challenge we may devise solutions and
devise new ways of making policies and
reaching agreements and implementing
them which enables us to to meet their
challenge but I certainly don't think
that the way in which the world has been
run even since 1945 let alone before on
the face of it has at all a good
probability of measuring up to to the
problems that were into that in the in
the question thank you very much here's
another question that calls upon your
powers of prophecy what do you think
will be the next economic theory to
challenge capitalism now that socialism
communism are viewed as failures or will
there be such a theory another very
profound and important question to which
also I don't know the answer if I didn't
know what it was I would be advocating
it myself I suppose I on the face of it
I don't expect there to be a new great
ideology in an economically based
ideology I think that the story of
Marxism that species of communism it has
been an extraordinary story it really
did were start from the very largely
from the writings of one man Karl Marx
and spread and developed into a
ideological system which then became
part of the governance of significant
parts of the world and part of the
competition in the world between two
powerful competing systems I don't think
it is very likely that something like
that will happen again I think at the
moment anyway we are rather more
skeptical about ideologies I think that
at the moment
and for the Syria for the next decade or
so the absent give or take the thought
of very short term crises the world is
working sufficiently successfully fought
for fifth of the world's population to
make it somewhat unlikely that there
would be a rush into a new ideological
system that would threaten in some
fundamental way to overturn the existing
system i think that the collapse of
communism has also contributed to a lack
of confidence in ideologies as such and
to a preference for or people think of
as more pragmatic systems though of
course pragmatism is itself an ideology
and what the the political economic
arrangements under which most of us live
are themselves the results of of
theories and of ideas and of political
science and philosophers and writers
better theories we have to hope and
believe than than those Karl Marx but
nonetheless they are in one sense no
less theoretical but I think it's rather
unlikely that we shall that somebody
will write a book like Das Kapital which
will take over the minds of large
numbers of people in the economic sphere
what might happen in the field of of
religion or spiritual affairs spiritual
thinking and so on that is a much wider
speculation it seems to me that it is
always possible that spiritual
revolutions of one kind another new
religions may capture people's
imaginations and persuade them right
there wrongly that that is what they
need but I'm rather skeptical that there
will be another great ideology if the
were one I presume it would be based
initially on some kind of rejection of
those parts of the existing world which
don't seem to work very well the things
that young people at Seattle and at
washington and i think this coming
weekend possibly improv
wish to protest about and reject about
the existing world all gathered together
under the title of globalization is a
very long agenda of completely not
coherently related items and anything
all of these people at all agree with
each other about what it is that's wrong
they all but they all agree with that as
well they haven't got it now they have
now got the kind of world that they
would like to see I think there could be
a revival of nationalism is what it
boils down to and rejection of
globalization is essentially a wish to
assert the control and identity of more
local units than the globe and those are
likely to be essentially nation states
or even possibly smaller states so if
the were an ideological shift I think it
would be one in the direction of
nationalism of the things that go with
economic nationalism self-sufficiency
barriers to to free trade barriers to
movements of currency and money a return
in some ways to the to the world as it
was in the 1930s and has been at other
times in in history in my opinion the
consequences that would be very grave
not only for economic success but also
for peace of the world because economic
nationalism engenders frictions and
conflicts between nations which are and
have in the past led to war and which
are extremely dangerous but I think if
the were an ideological shift the most
likely direction which it would go would
be in that direction I hope that doesn't
happen because I think that would be
very bad news for almost all of us
how would you compare the Industrial
Revolution to today's internet
revolution will the changes that are
being wrought today at the same
fundamental long-lasting and
wide-ranging impact of the Industrial
Revolution you ask all the right
questions I discussed this question a
little bit in the book now forgive a
short route sir now there are people
serious informed and intelligent people
who do claim that the internet or at
least more broadly the artificial
intelligence revolution the IT
revolution is to be compared in
importance with the other two great
revolutions in the economic story the
Agricultural Revolution and the
Industrial Revolution now the test that
one has to apply to put them in that
league that that's that's the Super
League that's they the National League
as it were of economic events and there
are only two so far the last 12,000
years so the tests are pretty demanding
to get into that class the tests are
that that they have a transforming
effect there's another test that I've
invented this is taking it from the
literature that they have a transforming
effect on the economic lives of most
people that following the Agricultural
Revolution following the Industrial
Revolution the lives of most people in
the places where they occurred was not
barely affected or hugely affected but
transformed and the question is whether
the internet or ite or artificial
intelligence whatever you want to
precisely take on will have a comparably
transforming effect I comparably my
judgment is that we cannot yet say that
we may never be able to say it that
there is not evidence yet it's not to be
excluded as a possibility dun dun track
but there is no evidence yet that would
justify one insane
in that fundamental way the lives of
most people will be transformed in
consequence of this immensely important
development that clearly ite enables
very large numbers of people to do very
large numbers of things more
conveniently more quickly more
efficiently more successfully than they
could do them before and clearly in a
sense it enables more people to do
things that previously only a few people
could do but whether it yet enables
people in general to do things which
could not be done at all before which is
essentially what agricultural the
industrial revolutions did seems to me
to be going beyond anything that we can
get see for certain on the ground there
are some things that they can probably
do that couldn't be done before at all
particularly in the air is a very very
large number crunching like long-range
weather forecasting but as a general
transforming experience of mankind in
general no I didn't think it yet belongs
in that class I may be proved to be
wrong I might be proved to be wrong
quite quickly though I don't think one
could make a judgment of that kind and
in less than about 50 years from the
beginning of the IT the serious
beginning of the IT revolution here's
another question you write that the
black death had a serious impact upon
industrial production in Egypt and Syria
resulting in the Sultan's a decision to
take an oppressive approach to
collecting revenues would you predict
the same of hiv/aids
I mean good trouble about the black
death because in response to an SOS from
some editor of Time magazine I allowed
myself to contributor brief these about
one aspect of the Black Death that
interested him which is in my book which
is that rather over a hundred years
after it some of the effects of the huge
drop in population to get that something
like a thirty percent of the population
of Europe was killed by the Black Death
and the population of Europe fell for a
while very significantly some of the
long-range consequences of that were
economically important in that it by
making labor extremely scarce it hugely
increased its bargaining power with the
existing in landowners and employers of
labour and led to the consequence
defective breakdown of the feudal system
and open the gateways it has been argued
to more modern economic developments and
I was accused by this one correspondent
I have of writing this in the context of
a general discussion of HIV of trying to
see a silver lining in the aids problem
that wasn't what I wanted to argue and I
don't think that anything can possibly
conceivably lead us to say either of the
black death or of AIDS that in some
sense this is worthwhile because of
long-range economic consequences I
certainly think that if AIDS reaches the
point is an epidemic or pandemic of
having the sort of effect on numbers or
even a fraction of the effectual numbers
of the black death had yes there may
well be governments in parts of Africa
and elsewhere who would be alarmed at
the effects on their revenue and who
would seek to maintain their revenue in
order to maintain their expenditure
plans and thereby increase the tax
burden they imposed
per head and clearly that would that
would add to the oppression but one
should that's the only part of one of
the negative effects of an appalling
events such as the Black Death if the
the immediate effects of the black death
of 50 to 100 years were economically
negative quite apart from the universal
human tragedy of it the productive
capacity of Europe effectively collapsed
markets collapsed there was nobody to
Chris gravely reduced numbers producing
things greatly reduced numbers can see
anything the economic effect was
exceedingly catastrophic li- and nobody
should be under any illusions in my
opinion that if aids were to have any
similar effect I don't yet know whether
it might but if it were that there is
there's anything good about this there
is nothing good about it at all it would
be first and foremost it would be a
human tragedy on earth inconceivably or
barely conceivably large scale but
secondly economically it would all of
its effects for a very long time would
be extremely negative and if there were
very any very very very long-term
positive effects of the kind that back
death had in shaking up the feudal
system they're so far far away that I
don't think we need to spend very much
time thinking about them unfortunately
we've reached that point in the program
where we have time for just one last
question and this is from an audience
member thinking about a little different
questions and the question is what is
the most amusing thing that happened to
you as ambassador to the United States
from Great Britain I hey
or more than 0 cover questions no my
mind always goes entirely and completely
blank and it's gone entirely and
completely blank on this occasion
amusement is not the predominant theme
of that particular job you work
incredibly hard incredibly long hours
and i used to say quite regularly they
need a younger man for this job i was
then under 40 so i used to get a bit of
a titter for that but not not much more
I will think about this and if I can
think of it I shall relay it to you
later on in the proceedings it was a
wonderful experience and an uplifting
experience and an important experience
but I wouldn't say it was in general and
amusing experience but I thanks
ambassador Peter J author of the wealth
of man and economics editor the BBC
thank you
I'd also like to thank our audio
audience listening on radio and watching
on c-span now this meeting of the
Commonwealth Club of California is
adjourned
free money